a texas death row inmate scheduled to be
executed next week is pleading with
governor greg abbott
to spare his life quinton jones was
convicted of killing his great aunt back
in 1999
when he was just 20 years old his
supporters say that jones has turned his
life around in prison
and is remorseful omar villafranca spoke
to one of jones's family members who
hopes
that this execution will be stopped omar
very interesting story good morning to
you
good morning according to the death
penalty information center texas leads
the nation
in executions each year and of the six
people scheduled to die this year
five are here in texas and now quentin
jones is making a final plea
hoping he is not one of them all i'm
asking you to do
if you find in your heart mr heaven is
to give me
a second chance in life quentin jones is
set to be executed on may 19th
with the help of the new york times he
made this video asking texas governor
greg
abbott to grant him clemency which would
stop his execution
but keep him behind bars how is the
person you are now different from the
person
you were when you got on death row 21
years ago
more thoughtful
love myself more jones does not deny
that in 1999 he brutally killed his
great aunt berthina bryant
for 30 dollars to buy drugs he had an
unimaginably difficult childhood
addiction and neglect he said to me you
know that
his childhood didn't excuse what he did
writer suleika jawad wrote an opinion
article this week
advocating for jones's clemency because
she says
he's transformed his life for the last
decade
she's been his pen pal and says he
helped her get through cancer treatment
what in those letters or in that
interaction
has changed your mind that he has
changed i've
had the privilege of witnessing
his compassion his thoughtfulness and
i'm not the only one
uh he's had many other pen pals around
the world
and this had a huge impact on their
lives as well
have you forgiven quentin i have
forgiven him
i love him very much jones great aunt
maddie long is the sister of his victim
she and her sister were extremely close
what would you tell governor abbott if
he's watching this interview
i think the governor should spare him
because he have changed and he's a
different
person than he used to be according to
the non-profit death penalty information
center
in texas a death penalty case costs an
average of 2.3 million dollars
about three times the cost of
imprisoning someone in a single cell
at the highest security level for 40
years
overall support for the death penalty is
declining in the u.s
according to a 2019 poll from gallup
only 36 percent of americans
chose the death penalty when asked
whether the death penalty or
life without possibility of parole is
the better penalty for murder
when you look at a case like this one
really the only question is whether
people believe that the death penalty is
an appropriate kind of punishment
for this particular set of facts paul
cassell is a professor at the college of
law
at the university of utah you can make
two arguments in support of the death
penalty
one is the utilitarian argument that we
can deter
crime by imposing the most serious
punishment for
first-degree murder and the other is the
retributive argument that if we look
backward we want the punishment to fit
the crime
republican governor greg abbott has only
granted clemency
one other time to someone on death row i
understand too that
if i do get clemson i know that
instead of dying on the 19th i may die
years later
but it won't be in the free room it'll
be in prison
and i can accept that because there's
other avenues and prisons that i can
take
to better myself and to better others
along the way
more than 120 thousand people have
signed a change.org petition
asking texas governor greg abbott to
grant jones clemency
we reached out to the governor's office
but did not hear back
the texas board of pardon and paroles is
considering clemency
and once they make their decision which
could actually happen today
they'll pass that recommendation on to
governor abbott vlad
all right we'll be watching omar thank
you very much